hi everyone it's Jerry I have a simple
and instructive 10 move game to share
with you this was a Blitz game played in
New York 1963 between Bobby fiser on the
white end and Dr Ruben fine psychologist
author and of course fantastic chess
player however on this particular day
not his best effort let's see what
happened now as I play through this one
I'm going to be highlighting several
tactical
variations in addition to that I'll be
making many technical notes don't
overlook the technical part of this one
it's really what helps shape this game
what helps uh create the conditions for
such a brief
Victory the opening is a filor
defense might put some pressure on E5
easy enough to
defend when does Fischer capture on E5
not here
in what way would black be helped by
this capture the bishop has two new
squares and you might reason the queen
is helped if the bishop is on C5 it
seems like a perfectly reasonable post
for the black queen would be on
E7 okay in this game it's Bishop C4
fiser points at the weakest Square in
Black's Camp the followup
C6 very easy for black to already go
wrong
you could go wrong by developing the
Knight this isn't wrong because Knight
G5 wins right away if you play Knight G5
here black can defend with D5 this
blocks the Bishop from seeing F7 however
white could first initiate the capture
on E5 and then play Knight
G5 no D5 in this position no
defense okay one other very variation is
to capture with the Knight and that
would bring us to this position here
where the king now finds himself as the
defender and Defenders get deflected
Bishop takes F7 is a tactical shot that
Nets white a
pawn what are Black's options this is
the simple continuation White's just up
the pawn and the one that's a bit more
sophisticated is to take the bishop
allow the queen to be captured and then
you get it back in a couple moves and
note how white recaptures on D2 with the
Knight they just in the nick of time to
hang on to the extra
Pawn so in this game it is
C6 fiser places an emphasis on kingside
development he's not going with Knight
C3 here especially with this Pawn on C6
six the queen Knight will not have as
easy a Time exerting pressure on Black's
Camp White's King Rook however will find
it much easier to put pressure on
Black's
position okay we continue in this game
it is Bishop
E7 if the Knight goes here we'll have
those same tactics available kicking off
with the capture on
E5 with Bishop D7 black is well aware of
the pressure on this point and is
tweaking the move order going with the
bishop first and is next looking to
develop the Knight and then if white
tries to go in for this pressure on F7
black will be a move away castles from
having F7 secure The Rook would be there
just in
time okay I said early on note when
fiser captures on E5
this is when when Black puts the bishop
on
E7 that's when he initiates the capture
now why is this the moment why is this a
better moment to capture an E5 well
white is basically saying you know if
you want to put your Bishop on C5 now
you have to spend another Tempo it's
going to cost you a little bit more you
already invested one move
okay we continue in this position with
Queen to E2 now here are
some
interesting tactics check this variation
out you could also go with Knight
G5 right away seems like you're losing
the Knight there's two attackers on this
and only one Defender this is considered
a top move second best is the move that
fiser played Queen to E2
but check these lines out I want to
highlight a couple lines kicking off
with Knight G5 right here if Bishop
captures Knight white is basically going
to win the bishop pair Queen
H5 targets F7 threatens mate and there's
two attackers now on the bishop this is
how white gets uh acquires the bishop
pair so might look something like this
queen E7 Queen takes Bishop white plays
with the two Bishops is doing very well
here one other variation this one is way
too cool not to show let's say black
doesn't want to play this variation sees
what's happening with Queen H5 white
getting the bishop pair if the Knight
goes to the edge here are you ready for
this next move Knight H6 defends F7
check this move out Knight
E6 absolutely crushing
move how does this play out Pawn takes
Knight Bishop takes Knight Pawn takes
Bishop it's already going to be
mate Queen H5 check King f8 and how do
you stop Queen F7 mate there's only one
move that stops Queen F7 mate and when
you play this move you get hit with
another mate crisscross game
over okay Knight G5 pretty cool move
right here in this game though it's
Queen E2 a square is now opened up for
the king Rook only now is there Knight G
to F6 considered best in this position
for black is to flick in H6 ruling out
Knight G5 in this game though it's
Knight G to
F6 white puts the Rook on the open open
file pressure on Black's position
there's now a pin there's now a threat
to take on
E5 watch how easy it is to go wrong when
you're in a pin usually you want to get
out of that pin right away and that's
exactly how black plays it here the move
in this position Queen C7 it's a losing
move what's considered best is B5 not
only attacking the bishop but
controlling C4 we're going to see soon
enough why that's important in this game
though it's Queen C7 and white is
already
winning white goes in for the sensitive
F7 Square black thinks he's fine castles
secures F7 it's actually not secure
though here comes the final move of this
one and that is Bishop takes f F7 check
black
resigns what do you do here first of all
if you took with the Knight this would
be
bad you don't want to give up the two
minor
pieces and only get the uh a rook and
pawn it's almost always favoring the
side with the the minor pieces this
position is no different by taking with
the bishop this is a clearance sacrifice
you might describe it as a clearance
sacrifice
this square is now opened up for the
queen so if you take with the Rook the
game would follow Queen C4 and there's
no
defense white will soon be winning the
exchange game
over any other
option King here you simply go into E6
and with this variation you're going to
be winning The Rook so that's as far as
it goes this tactical shot is avail
available and black simply threw in the
towel after just these 10 moves so what
just happened here a player as good as
Ruben fine who was aware of the
vulnerable F7 Square to a degree still
fell for a
tactic if it's happening against him How
likely do you think a tactic like that
can land against one of your
opponents remember the finer points
through throughout that created
conditions for this tactic to be
successful anyhow Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye